>> Tucker: WELL GOOD EVENING
AND WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
I AM WILL CAIN, IN FOR TUCKER.
A DAY AFTER THE FBI'S RAID ON
FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP WE
ARE STARTING TO SEE WHAT A
PERMANENT NATIONAL SPLIT LOOKS
LIKE.
A DIVORCE.
NOBODY WANTS TO SAY IT OUT LOUD
BUT IT'S TRUE.
AND THIS IS NOT SIMPLY A BREAK
BETWEEN DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS.
NO, THAT'S TOO SIMPLE.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS DIVIDE
BETWEEN PEOPLE WHO ARE WILLING
TO USE THE POWER OF THE STATE TO
SILENCE THEIR OPPONENT, AND
THOSE WHO ARE UNWILLING.
WHAT'S THE HILL THIS COUNTRY
TOGETHER SINCE THE CIVIL WAR?
IT'S NOT THAT OF A FEDERAL CODE,
IT'S NOT EVEN THE BILL OF RIGHTS
COME AS IMPORTANT IS.
REMEMBER, THE SOVIET UNION HAD A
BILL OF RIGHTS FOR GUARANTEED
FREEDOM OF SPEECH AND EQUAL
RIGHTS.
BUT IN PRACTICE THE BOLSHEVIKS
SENT THEIR DISSIDENTS TO THE
GULAGS.
AS HE BOASTED, SHOW ME THE MAN,
I WILL SHOW YOU THE CRIME.
NOW WHAT'S KEPT US FUNCTIONING
THROUGH THE CENTURIES WHERE THE
BOLSHEVIKS FAILED IS THAT OUR
CONSTITUTION SEPARATED POWERS
AND PREVENTED A UNIT PARTY.
WE ALSO HAD AN UNDERSTANDING
THAT STATE POWER SHALL NOT BE
USED FOR IMPROPER POLITICAL
PURPOSES.
THE LAW MUST BE ENFORCED
EQUALLY, WITHOUT POLITICAL
CONSIDERATIONS.
AND ONCE YOU LOSE THAT COMMON
UNDERSTANDING, IT'S MUTUALLY
ASSURED DESTRUCTION.
NOBODY HAD ANY REASON TO UPHOLD
THE SYSTEM, SO THE SYSTEM WILL
COLLAPSE.
THE LATE ANTHONY SCALIA MADE
THIS POINT BACK IN OCTOBER OF
2011, SPEAKING BEFORE THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
IT'S ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
VIDEOS YOU CAN WATCH, AND HERE
IT IS.
SPEAK OF THE RESPONSE I WILL
GET, AND YOU WILL GET THIS FROM
ALMOST ANY AMERICAN, INCLUDING
THE WOMAN HE WAS TALKING TO AT
THE SUPERMARKET, THE ANSWER WOUD
BE, FREEDOM OF SPEECH, FREEDOM
OF THE PRESS, NO UNREASONABLE
SEARCHES AND SEIZURES.
THE MARVELOUS PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL OF RIGHTS.
WHAT DID I TELL THEM?
IF YOU THINK THAT A
BILL OF RIGHTS IS WHAT SETS US
APART, YOU'RE CRAZY.
EVERY BANANA REPUBLIC IN THE
WORLD HAS A BILL OF RIGHTS.
JUST WORDS ON PAPER.
WHAT OUR FRAMERS WOULD HAVE
CALLED A PARCHMENT GUARANTEE.
AND THE REASON IS THAT THE REAL
CONSTITUTION OF THE
SOVIET UNION, YOU THINK OF THE
WORD "CONSTITUTION" IT DOESN'T
MEAN A BILL, IT MEANS STRUCTURE.
SAY A PERSON HAS A SOUND
CONSTITUTION, THEY HAVE A SOUND
STRUCTURE.
THE REAL CONSTITUTION OF THE
SOVIET UNION, WHICH IS WHAT OUR
FRAMERS DEBATED THAT WHOLE
SUMMER IN PHILADELPHIA IN 1787,
THEY DIDN'T TALK ABOUT THE
BILL OF RIGHTS.
THAT WAS AN AFTERTHOUGHT, WASN'T
IT?
THAT CONSTITUTION OF THE
SOVIET UNION DID NOT PREVENT THE
CENTRALIZATION OF POWER, IN ONE
PERSON OR IN ONE PARTY.
AND WHEN THAT HAPPENS, THE GAME
IS OVER, THE BILL OF RIGHTS IS
JUST WHAT OUR FRAMERS WOULD CALL
A PARCHMENT GUARANTEE.
>> Will: THE GAME IS OVER.
MOST AMERICANS NOW, BY THE WAY,
IN BOTH PARTIES BELIEVE WE ARE
LIVING IN A BANANA REPUBLIC THAT
WAS JUST DESCRIBED BY ANTHONY
SCALIA.
79% OF AMERICANS BELIEVE THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM DEFENDS POLITICAL
INSIDERS.
TWO-THIRDS OF DEMOCRATS BELIEVE
THAT.
THE PRESIDENT'S SON CAN COMMIT
MULTIPLE FELONIES,, CORRUPTION
AND THE FEDERAL AUTHORITIES
WILL JUST IGNORE IT.
IN FACT, THEY WILL CALL THEM
RUSSIAN THIS INFORMATION.
A SITTING MEMBER OF CONGRESS CAN
SHARE BODILY FLUIDS AND
POTENTIALLY CLASSIFIED
MATERIALS, PRESUMABLY NOT ONE IN
THE SAME, WITH A CHINESE SPY AND
NO ONE IN THE FBI OR THE MED